وانت تحدثنا هذه الصور ايضا لكهرمان مرعش
طبعا احدى الولايات الاكثر تضررا في جنوب
تركيا كما نتابع معكم وكان المكان يعني
دمار كامل نتابع السيارات مهدمه ابنيه في
الارض سويت في الارض الناس في الشارع
وكانهم هم من كانوا في هذه الابنيه الان
لا مكان لهم ولا ولهم سوى الشارع طبعا كل
الدعوات والاصوات تنادي بالخروج الى اماكن
امنه والابتعاد عن البنايات والابنيه خوفا
من اي تداعيات اخرى للهزات الارتداديه
التي حصلت وايضا من التحذيرات الكبيره
ولكن قلل الخبراء من شانها من حديث عن
موجات ماده تسونامي طبعا المشاهد تصف يعني
خير دليل لا حاجه للتعبير بالكلمات عما
يجري في ولايه كهرمان مرعش حيث المباني
هناك حرب حرب مدمره حصلت في هذا المكان
الابنيه في الارض الابنيه سويت في الارض
مهدمه جميعها المنازل مهدمه هذه الصوره
ابلغ تعبير عما حصل جراء الزلزال الذي ضرب
جنوب تركيا بقوه
7.9 درجات طبعا كهرمان هي من ضمن الولايات
التي اصلا كان فيها عاصفه ثلجيه قويه
بالتالي اليوم
الدفاع المدني وايضا عمليات الانقاذ تعاني
من صعوبه اكثر ليس فقط على صعيد ما حصل
بسبب البنايات المهدمه وصعوبه انتشال
الضحايا والجرحى والجثث من تحت الانقاض
وايضا بسبب الثلوج المتراكمه التي تعيق
حركه السير وايضا تعيد حركه عمليات
الانقاذ هذه هي المشاهد التي يتم تداولها
وتصلنا وننقلها لكم اولا با على شاشه
العربيه ضمن هذه التغطيه تظهر حجم الدمار
الكبير في منطقه كهرمان مرشا مرعش في
تركيا في جنوب تركيا بالتحديد